wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
alles in ordnung
der helfer sinne wahrscheinlich wird sie
nicht an
du weißt dass du dich ausruhen musst du
warst im krankenhaus keine sorge
entschuldigung hätten sie auch mit ich
habe sie noch gar nicht gesehen
der mann ist gerade vorbei gekommen und
hat gefragt dabei helfen können ja das
mache ich sehr gerne was ist wirklich
sehr freundlich aber es geht nicht warum
nicht weil du nicht versichert bist es
könnte etwas passieren das ist kein
problem mir passiert sicher nichts das
denkt man immer aber ein umzug ist
gefährlich weil man sich ganz schnell
verletzen kann
du kannst dich am kopf verletzten ein
schrank an die auf den fuß fallen
du kannst auf der treppe stürzen du
kannst dich an klar schneien
ich habe sogar schon gesehen dass sich
jemand an der heizung verbrannt hat
wirklich okay dann viel erfolg
du lässt dich aber gut einstellbar